so there are 11 major muscle groups in
the body and i'm just going to go
through them really quickly i'm not
going to talk too much about the names
of the muscles but i want you to get a
sense for where they're located on the
body so the arm
the leg and the core
and i'll write that over here so
the 11 groups there are three
actually four in the arm three in the
leg and four in the core
and just being familiar with where these
muscles are is actually really really
helpful and powerful because when you go
to the gym or you're working out
somewhere else
it's important to stretch these muscle
groups out it's important to also focus
on each one and try to figure out which
one is weak or strong and develop
whichever one is uh imbalanced sometimes
the left and the right side are not
equal in their strength so it's
important to be aware of where they're
located and we're going to go through
that really quickly right now so
let's do the arm first you have
first the forearm and you can see that
one the best from the front
and above that
you have the bicep that's about right
there this is your bicep
and behind the bicep actually on the
other side is the tricep
that's right there
and above both the bicep and the tricep
is the shoulder and actually i'm going
to draw that right there you can
actually see it from the front and the
back i'm just going to draw it right
there just for simplicity so those are
the four arm muscles and now let's just
jump down to the leg
and put in the quads this is your
quadricep
and this is actually called the
quadricep because it's actually four
different muscles working together
and below the quads or actually on the
other side of the quads rather
is your hamstring so right here is your
hamstring
and i want to give a special kind of
shout out to the hamstring because
it does a lot of work and a lot of
people forget to stretch it out and you
can often get in a lot of pain from not
having a good stretched out hamstring
below it is the calf
here's the calf
and
the calf is
uh actually sitting on the opposite side
of the
bones in the lower leg the tibia and the
fibula which is why it's so bony on the
front part of your lower leg but on the
back it's very median muscley
so you have
three leg muscles there and now let's
put in the core muscle so you have let's
do the front first
so
right here is where people talk about
getting a six-pack your abs
that's an important muscle group
it helps you do sit-ups
and above it
is your chest so right here
is your chest
and
so there are two in the front
similarly there are two in the back and
so the back ones
um let me do
in yellow are your trapezius and
trapezius actually kind of comes down
like a diamond almost
kind of like that
and it helps with the neck and
upper back
and then almost like you have uh wings
in a way you have two other muscles or
actually another muscle two sides on it
called latissimus dorsi and
it's actually kind of the large spread
out muscle and i'm not drawing all of it
but basically kind of spreads all the
way through your back
and
this is
the major muscle of your back so when
people say you know i threw out my back
oftentimes if it's the lower back
they're talking about their latissimus
dorsi
and that means that we have now our four
core muscles shown up here as well so
counting them out we've got our 11
muscle groups and so just to
again go over very quickly we've got one
shoulder
bicep
forearm and tricep
in our leg we have our quads our
hamstring and our calf
and then in the core of our body we have
our abs our chest
our
upper back which would be the trapezius
in the lower back which is the
latissimus dorsi
those are 11 groups